[MUSIC PLAYING]
>>At the World Economic Forum in Davos every
year, YouTube sets up a
production base and invites the presidents,
dignitaries, and foreign
leaders in attendance to stop by and respond
via video to your question
and ideas about the world's most pressing
challenges.
So what do you want to ask the world leaders
in Davos?
Pose your idea or question or video or text
and submit at
YouTube.com/Davos.
You can vote on your favorite submissions
from others too.
We'll pose the top-voted submissions to the
world leaders at Davos when
they come to the YouTube booth, giving you
direct access to some of the
most powerful and influential people in the
world.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos today to join the
conversation.